let's find out  uh maybe like quincy five you can kind  of go bishop c bishop f1 or bishop all  the players playing incredibly quickly  because uh magnus has got no time on the  clock our board is not yeah our board is  not updating so maybe we should just  follow  oh  magnus not in great shape here pawn down  no more a pawns  and suffering  he just looks lost he has to take and  then takes rook takes bishop before sir  trick  wesley  hesitated for a moment but yeah wesley  wins that one  and uh uh well punishing  one a4 check out the moves i don't think  it was because of the opening frankly no  no the opening look good but uh  somewhere  do we have an update of the lifeboard